concern is growing for two british aid
workers missing in ukraine
45 year old paul yuri on the right and
22 year old dylan healey on the left a
uk-based non-profit organization says
they were detained by russian forces on
monday in the south east of the country
this hasn't been confirmed paul's mother
is frantic with worry
i come on it
thanks
i don't know what to do anymore i don't
know
it's horrible
i'mma i'll start since three a.m this
morning
watching sky news
glued to it
rewinding it over and over and over
missed anything
too caring i wish he was a horrible
person to be honest and i know that
sounds selfish but
you don't mess with the russians do you
fear two for dylan no one's had contact
with dylan so until they managed to
locate dylan and paul obviously
you know we could just hope that they're
still going and they're still you know
pushing through it and whatever they're
kind of enduring
it comes after scott sibley a former
soldier became the first british man
confirmed to have been killed in ukraine
since russia's invasion
unlike paul and dylan he'd gone to help
fight alongside ukrainian forces
a spokesperson for ukraine's
international legion said in the middle
of a war there are of course casualties
on both sides and the international
legion is no exception and has also
suffered losses our thoughts and prayers
go to the families of the fallen their
sacrifice will not be in vain and their
bravery will be a beacon for the battle
ahead of us
russia has also paraded another british
man named as andrew hill on television
after he was captured by russian forces
in the southern region of mikolayev
sky news has chosen not to show the
footage he appeared to have been injured
and was dressed in military-style
clothes
this british man who went to syria to
combat islamic state has now been doing
aid work in ukraine
what drives us abroad is selflessness
and we are selfless to complete
strangers but the
tragedy is that the people who suffer
the most are our own family so there's a
huge amount of self selfishness there as
well
for the families of paul dylan and
andrew they will just want their loved
ones home
debra haynes sky news keeve